a state of emergency has been declared
in part of the u.s state of california
as a wildfire spreads rapidly there the
oak fire as it's been named broke out
near yosemite national park it's
threatening thousands of homes as well
as most some of the most famous trees in
the world
this fire is closing in on the largest
growth of giant sequoias in yosemite
national park
firefighters are hoping to protect these
ancient trees
some of the largest in the world
homes businesses cars
the flames are devouring everything
thick smoke has darkened the park's
scenic views
more than six thousand people including
campers have been told to get out
they came by about 15-20 minutes ago and
told us that everybody's got to go about
four o'clock the power went out
and the fire's been coming towards us
faster and faster
weeks ago firefighters installed
sprinklers in the grove to keep the
trunks moist
in a bit to keep the flames away from
the sequoias including one of its most
famous attractions
this 3000 year old sequoia known as the
grizzly giant
in recent years california wildfires
have destroyed thousands of giant
sequoias
fire officials say it could take days
before this one is fully contained
warmer temperatures and extreme drought
conditions linked to climate change are
making wildfires more common
the yosemite blaze comes as much of the
u.s is in the grips of an extreme heat
wave
parts of california are seeing
temperatures close to 40 degrees celsius
greece has been battling major wildfires
amid a heat wave that's expected to last
for days
on the island of lesbos hundreds of
residents and tourists alike have been
evacuated from a popular resort
fierce flames have also raged for four
days in the country's national park near
the border with turkey
the nearby village evacuated overnight
the heat wave began on saturday it's
expected to reach 42 degrees
celsius
and let's get more on that i am joined
now by dw correspondent florian schmitz
who's in tesla nikki
florian very good to see you over there
first of all just give us an update on
the situation
um well we're looking back on a very
difficult week with very strong blazes
uh more than 50 of them just during the
past 36 hours you already mentioned the
most critical one in everest in that yes
a protected force that has been on fire
for the past four days and four weeks
very strong winds at the various um and
the temperatures make it very hard to
control the fires and the strategy at
the moment seems to be that to
extinguish the already burning fires but
to prevent them from uh spreading uh you
also mentioned the other critical
situation that we're having uh in lesbos
where a holiday resort had to be
evacuated um i just talked to a
colleague of mine about an hour ago who
is on site and she told me that fires
keep flaring up but that the overall
situation uh seems to be improving
airplanes uh try to extinguish the fires
with sea water and help um have a ride
from the mainland in the morning
now greece sees fires every summer it's
not particularly unusual is there
anything that makes these fires this
year different
well definitely the experiences that we
made last year with the the devastating
fires in evie on the island of eddie and
in athens um a major
mistake that the government made last
year for example was to activate the
european civil protection mechanism way
too late so that that help from other
european countries arrived when the
fires were already out
now this year greek firefighters were
joined early by colleagues from six
european countries they prepare together
they try to coordinate also some um
investments were made into heavy
machinery and an additional 500
firefighters have been have been
employed by the state however um
environmental organizations criticized
the government for still not having
learned from the mistakes made last year
and the
namely not taking the matter of
prevention as serious as they should
have um the fourth have not been
properly prepared not not most of them
anyways so it makes it very hard when a
fire once breaks out to um to actually
extinguish them and also this still
seems to be a lack of coordination
especially when it comes to local
authorities where each authority has
their own fire plan and own plan to
react in case of emergency which of
course makes it
very difficult and the major problem is
that athens seems to have invested a lot
of money into an already over inflated
police force now
athens already employs 500 police
officers on 100 000 citizens which is a
way above the european average and we've
seen um a fire in athens uh in in
one of the gates of athens just last
week where 485 firefighters were
deployed and
626 policemen so people have been
sharing pictures on the social media of
policemen trying to extinguish small
fires with watering cans and people are
criticizing the government um for not
investing enough money into the
firefighting body
do you body dw correspondent florian schmitz from
the greek city of tesla nikki with the
latest thanks very much